while anime is generally a medium for
the Youth to enjoy and one that tickles
their idealism it also has no shortage
of badass old men older characters
grizzled veterans and the like you have
their fair share of awesome fights and
entrances so for today we're going to be
taking a look at my favorite moments
where all the characters showed that
they still have it with an epic entrance
and flex to boot will open up with a
bang thanks to the Timeless classic
Hunter Hunter
foreign
[Music]
you know what's coming Dragon dive in an
arc full of memorable moments how could
we ever forget the awesome entrance
nataro and Zeno pulled the tarot is one
of my favorite mental characters and
he's got no shortage of cool moments the
way Dragon dive was presented in anime
form the team truly nailed it for the
chairman of the hunters Association
anything less would be a crime the sheer
awesomeness of the Dragon dive only
serves as a preview for other memorable
fights later in the arc after all he did
steal the show with one of the most epic
battles this Arc gave us matched only by
the gone ones this is a goosebump
inducing moment befitting of one of the
best arcs Shonen anime has ever seen
next we move on with girocho returning
in glory
when talking about girocho our fondest
memory of him is probably the moment in
episode 211. remember when he gave
gintoki a lesson in pain and also a
fight filled with emotion which saw Kim
Toki actually go out and still lose
almost 150 episodes later he makes his
Grand return and it's a scene that's
nearly as memorable as that kintoki
fight it's a scene that got fans going
wild seeing girocho arrive with his gang
to even the odds with something that
some people expected but all that
knowledge doesn't make this moment any
less awesome after such a heated fight
that they had before it felt awesome to
see gintoki and jirocho team up the
succeeding flashback also gives us some
much wanted backstory for jirocho
shedding more light about his pass with
otose in terms of actual fighting I
still have the fight against Kentucky as
my best girojo moment but this one's not
too shabby in comparison
anyone out for some badass Butler action
well Walter's got you covered
[Music]
battle Butlers are quite the fun Trope
in anime don't you think so we've got
the sebastians from both Black Butler
and Overlord but how about Walter from
Helsing ultimate with the way I talked
about Helsing in the previous videos I
wouldn't blame you for thinking it's the
Alucard show what if I tell you Walter's
just as crazy opium badass as our
protagonist but in his own way here
Walter gives our guests a very warm
welcome complete with razor wires a very
intimidating orders for the presence and
a methodical approach to chaos fighting
struggle as they might these enemies
stand no chance and it's old Walter
we're talking about here imagine Prime
Walter coming in and laying waste to
these Falls sure it's not as
awe-inspiring as alucard's Feats and
Transformations but when you consider
the context and see what Walter at his
current state is capable of it's still a
pretty damn good entrance and fight
isn't it fight is a stretch actually
more like a Slaughter if you ask me
foreign
is here with a less talked about
appearance
[Music]
July is known for a lot of cool moments
in the entire run of Naruto however one
moment that I feel doesn't get enough
focus is the time he saved Naruto and
Sasuke from Itachi and Kisame you know
the time way back when Itachi was still
meant to be evil it's a pleasant
surprise to have Jiraiya appear just
when our two protagonists are on the
brink and his appearance gives a much
needed dose of light-heartedness and
relief in this moment of tension and
then Sasuke just had to try and steal
the spotlight before getting punished
for it with that little commercial out
of the way though we get Uriah easily
turning the tides forcing the villains
to escape all without those hacks eyes
demon beasts and the like people are
still debating now whether Jiraiya can
take both of them or not but I think
it's much less of a concern than just
actually appreciating the moment
remembering Jiraiya for a pretty cool
entrance and Save that doesn't get
talked about enough also a subtle shot
of power as Itachi and Kisame both don't
want a piece of him when they're not of
full strength
hey if you feel bad for not being able
to watch the shows here legally help is
on the way expressvpn's here to solve
all those woes expressvpn's the service
that helps open up the internet for you
but the Advent of anime streaming
services one thing remains constant the
issues of region locking thankfully
though with expressvpn you can
temporarily pretend that you're in a
place like America or the UK and access
the full library of anime that's
available there on the more mainstream
channels all you have to do is pull up
this list of servers pick your server
and connect to it with the click of a
button pick this VPN is what I used when
I was in China and wanted to keep up
with seasonal anime speaking of China
expressvpn also allowed me to use
various social media sites in spite of
the restrictions which allowed me to not
miss a beat when it comes to getting in
touch with friends or checking my status
here on YouTube let's help you get
started I've got a link down below that
will give you a great deal I'm talking
three months free of expressvpn and less
than seven dollars a month for an entire
year just head on to expressvpn.com
vinitube for more details online
protection and the ability to break
Regional borders for less than seven
dollars I mean that's just a steal right
there next up we have hideyoshi
[Music]
there are many incarnations of toyotomi
hideyoshi in anime but are any of them
as badass as the one from sengoku basara
appearing on top of a hill hideyoshi
bravely faces a literal horde of archers
looking to give him a swift end of
course though it's not meant to be we're
all expecting him to pull something cool
to overcome the supposed stacked odds
but if anyone actually expect him to
step forward draw no weapon and simply
just wave his hands creating a shock
wave strong enough to not only repel the
reign of arrows but to just send
everything back all by himself it's
nothing short of impressive and he caps
It Off by literally opening the heavens
that shine a spotlight on him that's a
major last boss Vibes right there I'm
telling you just the APT entrance for
someone who's in my book the most
impressive amongst the major characters
in this show I mean imagine fighting and
being such a big badass to dominate the
battlefield without a single weapon
doesn't get more hardcore than that now
does it
Yamamoto versus yuha started off with an
explosion if you will
[Music]
for so long we've all Faithfully waited
for the day when Yamamoto finally
unleashes his full strength and shows us
why he's the strongest of the gote in
the captain Commander well the time has
finally come and Yamamoto arrives in
front of yuha in a blazing Inferno it's
an entrance that gave me and bleach fans
all over the world something to cheer
for yamamoto's arrival coming off
utterly annihilating some Quincy slob
shines a ray of Hope for the Shinigami
who've been dropping like flies
beforehand the atmosphere this entry has
been perfectly captured by the anime
team and it's followed by what many
consider it to be the best episode of
the Thousand-Year blood Wars first core
a total Showcase of power that gives
Credence to yamamoto's title one that I
also featured in another video not so
long ago when even Eisen doesn't want to
mess with you you know you're something
special and Yamamoto proceeds to show us
why in The Following episode
King Bradley also has a pretty cool
entrance and fight if you ask me
we've all seen Madara showcase the power
scaling of his own series Universe with
an impressive feat of soloing an entire
Army but he's not the first to do it
granted King Bradley may also not be the
first one either but this is one of the
first memories I have of a villain doing
it imagine a guy going solo and just
rushing everything down leaving behind a
trail of Destruction I mean it's the
stuff of nightmares if you're one of the
poor soldiers caught in the crosshairs
all the time King Bradley approaches his
enemies with an uncanny almost unnerving
sense of calm showing complete control
over the situation when the result was
never in doubt and the most stunning
part of this was once you settle down
and look back at it King Bradley wasn't
in his prime he's aged through the years
and essentially approaching senior years
at this point this moment is memorable
for a lot of things it firmly
established King Bradley as an immense
threat who still mows down enemies like
nothing even way past his prime
we're wrapping this list out with none
other than a one-piece entry here's
Rayleigh versus
[Music]
back in the era of one piece when
everything was just simpler Rayleigh
made an entrance that really left an
impression just when gizaru's got our
heroes dead to Right Here Comes This old
man kicking an attack away and taking
over the battle it's a moment that ages
extremely well when you look back at it
right now and think of the power scaling
at the time this is a guy who's really
old but at the same time seeing him take
on an admiral and actually keeping up
with him was a thing that amazes you
even more when you look back with
hindsight by all means no one who's
passed his Prime and that supposedly
Rusty should be able to keep up with
freaking kizaru but this man did it I
personally hope the fight would have
lasted longer but it's not exactly a
serious fight in this case is it so
that's understandable I guess still some
amazing feats from Good Old Rayleigh
here who knows what raelian is prime can
do
cousin
and that's gotta do it make sure to
leave a like if you enjoyed this video
and comment down what you think is the
best entrance that I featured and don't
forget to check out expressvpn the best
VPN offering service and efficiency like
no other thank you again for watching
and I'll see you next time be sure to be
there